- Have you blown any money
on an indulgence of any sort?
- Ooh, well you know, a
lot in my life has changed.
Except for the fact that I'm very cheap,
(laughing)
and that will be consistent.
But there is one thing I splurge on,
I feel like it's very relatable though.
The one thing I will splurge on is
birthday parties for my dog.
(laughing)
I will spend
- Does everyone relate?
- any amount of money
on my dog.
She knows what I'm talking
about, she's like--
(clapping)
She knows what I'm talking about.
(laughing)
On my dog,
I will spend anything.
- Not your birthday,
not yours?
- Listen, my birthday
I'll be up in a Denny's,
just being casual okay,
but my dogs birthday--
- [Kelly] Moons Over My Hammy.
- So he recently turned two,
I know, they grow up so fast.
- Mine just turned two.
- Oh really?
- Henry, yeah.
- When we're the same.
- Yeah, we're the same human.
- My dog turned two and I gave him a
Harry Potter themed birthday.
(laughing)
Yes.
- [Kelly] I love Harry Potter.
- [Lilly] Yes!
Have you seen this wizard?
- It took place in "Dogwarts",
thank you, thank you!
(laughing)
Thank you!
- [Kelly] I love Harry Potter as well.
- [Lilly] I mean, it was great.
All of his dog friends came,
I made all these cupcakes,
look at him, he's dressed as a Gryffindor,
I mean it's just a
whole thing.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
I love you.
- Thank you.
- That's so cute that you
spend your money on others,
- Oh absolutely.
- I do the same, totally.
(laughing)
- I feel like I have
my priorities in check.
- Me too.
Mine are different though.
(laughing)
I was like, Happy Birthday Henry.
Snuggle.
(laughing)